hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to afterlife of the game now
since we're dead I'm assuming that we
can take all the time in the world we
don't need to be in a blind mad rush to
get into the grave so here we go
oh [ __ ] god dammit fly ass [ __ ] oh it's
like flappy bird
ah isn't this beautiful delightful
oh the lovely countryside hi moon how
you doing I'm only oh hey how's it going
spiders oh you be are you cool you cool
with me spider bros be cool okay I guess
we flew into heaven what the hell
happened
clean your computer oh holy [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] oh in a rich oh my god tiny
bugs dim Oh
silly banana septic oh my god oh no oh
no oh no individual man counter plays
the vanilla
I'm a deer yeah that's me oh my god
that's me oh wait oh [ __ ] after your
death your computer was given to your
youngest grandchild Timmy
he first opened it he saw stuff that
scarred him for life he now resides in a
mental hospital and grabs cute little
stick yeah good okay all right let's try
this I think I get I think I get it now
okay so I'm supposed to delete these
cake eating Irish master sits while
talking about fans markiplier loves you
it's literally me oh my god that's
that's Nick yeah this is a thing okay
um what's oh okay special porn Oh more
porn porn got it so my porn somewhat
porn yeah
protect what what am i protecting ninjas
Oh
exes mob poop who's throwing all this
poop in acts oh my god poor Capone
Oh get out of here I don't know how this
ghost is managing to do all this she was
hello all right then
revenge drag how Jorge then goodbye all
right Alan I don't know what you did
Alan are you scared
have you been properly spooked Oh
oh it took me a while to get what I was
doing
oh hi hi jack how's it yeah yeah good
get those subs Jack you those subs Oh
Sweden what the [ __ ] was that holy [ __ ]
I was not ready for that okay tries
again double-click mode bye jack I guess
you died make him laugh what's green
fuzzy and if it fell out a tree would
kill you
Jeff tag Jack I bet you're expecting it
you're joking but that's a pool table
what's the difference between a snowman
and snow woman the snow balls
what do you call a Mexican downing in
mayonnaise Cinco de Mayo oh come on now
which bees produce milk boobies
what do you call a sheep with no legs a
cloud I'm the best ghost whoa okay oh
[ __ ] oh my god uh Jesus yeah oh man I'm
so good at whatever the hell this is
yeah oh I don't even get to dance my
[ __ ] Oh
dunk it all right head uh-huh
I know I can oh you failed god that's
terrible for you huh
math [ __ ] well I mean Oh what you
[ __ ] so don't don't try that [ __ ] huh
grim oh not nice that was that was good
when you almost had that you know
had that buddy yeah all right dress up
how in man clothes jasm Oh Deadpool I
didn't saw I want to do Deadpool without
a shirt oh and his underwear yeah okay
then all right
the only thing you should fear more than
ghosts is it off [ __ ] off all right fine
full Deadpool yeah how about that
collect what Souls oh [ __ ] oh I'm
literally Deadpool oh oh [ __ ] oh god oh
god it's so hard to walk I'm a ghost why
am I trying to walk a [ __ ] where is it
chimichangas [ __ ] am i yeah huh ah [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] dude f uck okay good I got
there's more why's there gonna be more
Oh what kind of trick-or-treating
[ __ ] is this oh my god don't get it
ah but did it yeah like a drunken
Russian teenager okay collect but what
the [ __ ] I just did this can I get
through here no I cannot [ __ ] oh I I
think I had it I had it god damn it I
had it why did it say that I didn't have
it I had it where's the razor blade go I
don't know doesn't matter to me I'm a
ghost oh [ __ ] what did I do wrong
okay we're fine I thought it would bust
out what I'm a ghost I'm literally a
ghost what am i what the hell is this oh
is this the UH the Ghostbusters secret
super special [ __ ] trap of fire Oh
God huh good I'm out of here baby
oh yeah okay choose what highway to hell
stare with him alright
how it is
all right my choice oh hey dougie what
am i a Mike oh I have oh I didn't know
that I was in control here why is fires
Hal filled with ducks oh [ __ ] oh good
one touch any of these ducks I know how
dirty they are I guess okay yeah
welcome to hell okay oh yeah yeah I did
it
Burgie good great this was an experience
glad I did this
cool